[Musik]
hey und sterbe herzlich willkommen hier
heute zu einem ende von block 2 teil 2
war das ist der zweite teil
guten morgen ich liebe geht es dir heute
sorgen ja es ist eigentlich schon besser
ich habe heute allerdings nichts
gegessen das heißt freunde ich mache mir
jetzt erstmal was gibt's zum frühstück
getan
[Musik]
daraufhin über gestern in boston hatte
zusammen mit anderen auch mit dabei und
hat wieder irgendwelche anderen
taxifahrern gelabert 46 bereiche
eingeladene freunde ich herstelle wir
heute eine eigene fanpage gemeint wenn
ich hart arbeiten in der tat dieser
stelle heute eine insgesamt enthält für
mein eigenes profil und werde dann mit
anderen fanpages für mich schreiben
selbst schon sagen toll jetzt haben sie
auch die dümmsten hier verstanden
[Gelächter]
also meine damen und herren kommen wir
jetzt zu dem was im titel steht und zwar
werde ich mir jetzt das ist mein
normales instagram profils instagram
bekommst luca jedoch werde ich mir nun
einen neuen account kreieren wie ich
schon gesagt habe und diese quasi so als
teammanagerin konnte ich habe jetzt hier
eben schnell den account lucca staiger
meiler kreiert ich habe darunter
geschrieben einfach mal in meine
beschreibung ad leitha luca fanpage für
den besten der herr 10 x 10 x com jedoch
lohnen meine damen und herren werden
danke
[Musik]
als erstes laden wir hier dieses believe
in love foto übrigens sagen schön ein
jude fürs bearbeiten in die caption
schreibe ich jetzt einfach mal rohem
gegner du bist so schön liebe dein
lächeln
durch dich bin ich stark und die luxus
steht immer hinter dir egal was du tust
wo du auch gerade so ein erstes online
gutschein zweites bild nämlich jetzt
einfach dieses endet wo draufsteht you
make me happy und schreib einfach nur
die caps mit laserdrucker markieren das
ist das dritte bild was ich hochgeladen
habe einfach mit der käppchen rapid
sondersteuer lieblingsessen so sieht
mein profil mittlerweile aus also ich
habe jetzt schon fünf bilder hochgeladen
ich habe noch keinen like von der esa
luca bekommen das werden wir jetzt
allerdings ändern ich gehe jetzt nicht
einfach mal mit meinem profil also mit
laser auch das profil und leica kann man
alle bilder durch das heißt ich ändere
jetzt auch die beschreibung von dem
lukas steiner weiter profil und schreibe
fünf mal like no mgm und jetzt warten
wir was ich hier was tut also ich habe
immer noch null abonnenten vielleicht
foto kv ende hat auch noch mal ein foto
gezeigt dass dem werde ich jetzt erst
mal anschreiben und sagen danke für
deinen bei richtiger hat der jedes foto
von mir allerdings will ich ja nicht nur
mein profil lucca staiger meiler
irgendwie hochbringen dadurch dass ich
meine bilder selbst beim haupttäter und
sondern ich will ja mit fanpages
schreiben und mich quasi als auch eine
fanpage ausgeben aber ich bin eigentlich
luca das heißt ich dir jetzt einfach auf
den account von mir also von laser luca
und leite jetzt einfach mal alle bilder
auch wie ich ihnen die markiert wurde
durch
[Musik]
ich habe es irgendwie 130 bilder gezeigt
und ich habe noch einmal neue abonnenten
juden
[Musik]
klasse ich habe immer noch nur
abonnenten auf meinem account weiß was
ich euch das mal machen ein paar
sekunden später
ich bezweifle es plötzlich in der
zwischenzeit habe ich mich übrigens
riesig über meinen ersten abonnenten
gefreut und bin ich drauf und hab
gesehen dass bei jule dachte dass vechta
verden gewesen jedoch werde ich jetzt
nur taktik verfolgen und zwar werde ich
jetzt einfach fanpages anschreiben ich
schreibe zu gast und text vor den ich
unterschreiben werde ich bin eine neues
enthält sogar die merken das sofort dass
du nein ich habe den text 4000 fanpages
kuba freude diese seite jug a field die
hat auch ihr erstes bild von vier
stunden hoch klettert schon 19
abonnenten und ich habe immer noch nur
julius muss nach ganz hinten pages
folgen mir wurde gesagt dass ich mir
selbst vielleicht auch mal folgen sollte
ich habe gleich vor der fan page
gerichtet family mit tausend abonnenten
ich hätte mehr gerichtstermine danke für
dein leykauf meinem foto hat mir echt
mega viel bedeutet luca wendel und
teamworx haben laut gericht kann family
folgt jetzt auch nicht auf zurückkämpfen
folglich auf und jetzt gehe ich noch mal
hier auf das große dann habe ich drei
leichen dann schreibe ich auch mal der
eine fanpage hustinx für den like und
dann auch wieder hier sein herz und eine
pizza connection anderen pferde togo und
antwortet flughafen du es erfolgt alle
unterschlägt gut ich bin jetzt hier
gerade insgesamt 25 fanpages gefolgt so
einfach mal so ein paar leuten und ich
glaube mir wurde auch noch mal
geschrieben und zwar hat die luft page
mit optischen du hast echt coole bild.de
gab es eben eine coole bilder aber die
hier ist echt cool die luke schule
unterstrich fpd weil comedy hatte sie
geschrieben naja aber trotzdem cool und
die hat zu den zeiten geschrieben 15 5
20 15 uhr 27 wo ich nicht geantwortet
habe ich sie trotzdem an den start
gegangen und hat mir noch mal
geschrieben
das ist das ist echt und übernimmt
gerade deshalb ages anschreiben
konversationen führen bildern icon added
machen ist eine partnerseite geworden
julia hat jetzt irgendeine anfrage für
das ist eine partnerseite ach du hast
dass du deine haben
wir sind jetzt gerade noch circa eine
stunde lang verschiedensten fanpages
gefolgt wir haben neue bilder
hochgeladen
wir haben leute geschrieben wir haben
den kommentaren kommentieren werden ist
meiner familie fahren nach bielefeld und
auf der fahrt werde auch noch mal ganz
vielen trends folgen auf den opfer
schreiben bilder von den leuten und dann
werde ich heute abend auf diesem weg
fanpage account werde ich einen
livestream machen wo ich das ganze dann
auflöse für die leute die sind geklaut
gefolgt sind also quasi inprivate live
stream an alle fanpages die so kulant
und lies waren und setzten wir fahren
allerdings waren wir erstmals meinen
eltern nach
nach jeder feld wir sind zu hause alle
kommen freunde der grund warum wir hier
sind ist war eine folge von sarah sandra
vielleicht kennt ihr sie
dann hat ein schauspiel
wir waren da drin so für eine stunde und
das war die langweiligste stunde meines
lebens und ich fahre nach hause sarah
bleibt irgendwie noch da ich weiß auch
nicht warum auf jeden fall schauen wir
jetzt mal wie es mit der fanpage so
aussieht ist nicht cool hat den
kompletten autofahren dem bilder glide
wir sind anderen fanpages gefolgt und
meine damen und herren wir haben nun 43
opfern internet 543 mühlenfreunde das
habe ich jetzt einfach mal so einen
bildschirm übertragen da eingeblendet
also dass sie sind unsere beiträge
werden hier schon 28 lag sie haben wir
sogar selbst 34 leichter mit 27 6 320
mit 22 und ihr 27 als unser meist gleich
das bild ist dieses jahr unser als
kommentiertes bild ist das hier von
fluffy da haben wir tatsächlich eine
menge kommentare darunter und die ersten
leute sind sogar schon ein wenig da
nicht mal neidisch auf uns und zwar wie
auch immer du das geschafft hast diese
ganz leicht zu bekommen glückwunsch man
merkt aber da ist ein bisschen neid mit
drin aber freude das überraschendste ist
und damit hätten wir wirklich nie
gerechnet wenn sie auf die startseite
geben wir haben unfassbar viele leute
die uns angeschrieben haben wir haben
hier
rufst du noch jemanden wegen partner 88
leute haben das gesehen
kaka und eine menge sachen geschrieben
dann hier julie marie hat uns
geschrieben
die fragen nicht alle ob die mit unserer
partnerseite sein können als ob lukas
schon fünf mal gereicht hat und juli
erfolgt dass es wie hast du's bitte
hinbekommen dass luca sarah und julia
alle deine bilder licon ohne dass du sie
markiert hast ein bisschen besser
wir haben also jetzt dieses profil hier
erstellt lukas chyla weiler wo wir sechs
bilder hochgeladen haben heute bei den
tag verteilt und wir haben jetzt schon
340 abonnenten wir schreiben selber mit
anderen fern hält es für mich und jetzt
werde ich das ganze auflösen indem ich
ein livestream mache hallo
b
[Musik]
ein aufgeregter freude hier schon
gesehen hat wir sind lokale wären sofern
für mein video morgen erstellt und zwar
ich wollte undercover mit euch schreiben
und so tun wird vielleicht eine fanpage
herzinfarkt in jemanden krankenwagen zu
rufen
der erste deine anfrage geschickt hat
jetzt mit uns leid wir machen hallo kwg
ehrlich oder greift ich habe so etwas
noch nie gemacht dass ich so leute und
stream eingeladen habe ja wir also ich
hatte das bei anderen youtube angesehen
und amerika bei lauren greater so heißt
die kelly hatte das in deutschland habe
ich auch gemacht und da dachte ich mir
ich hätte das auch unser echt krass
funktioniert also
wir haben 40 abonnenten heute gekriegt
haben gerade einfach noch so 20 minuten
mit verschiedensten leuten live spielen
die wir da eingeladen haben und ja das
war jetzt quasi selbst experiment
sondern halt so eine eigene fanpage für
sich selbst was machen schreiben hat
alle leute so auf was er sich nie
gesehen hab ich halt einfach mega doch
das ganze mal auszutesten ich hoffe das
kann man jetzt nicht arrogant rüber oder
narzisstisch und dann keine anderen
passt dann bräuchte mit auf jeden fall
nicht bewirken sondern wir wollten nicht
einfach mal testen und schauen ob wir
follower kriegen und wir haben jetzt
gerade 46 abonnenten
wir wollten übrigens ganz kurz sagen
dass wir uns sehr gefreut haben über das
feedback unter dem letzten block also
unter dem ersten block dieser block 2
reihe und ich wollte noch mal danke
sagen dass das konzept bei euch so cool
ankamen das hier war jetzt der zweite
block dieser neuen blog staffel und ich
hoffe ja so ein bisschen mehr verstanden
was der sinn dahinter ist also ich
möchte halten blog machen und euch so
zeigen hey okay jetzt esse ich gerade
wasser blabla aber dass das eigentlich
nur so ein kleiner
der zu beginn und zum ende konnte
mittendrin ist quasi so das thema des
blogs das heißt in diesem fall halt dass
wir uns so eine fanpage erstellt haben
für mich selbst und übermorgen sehen uns
dann wieder in einem blog wo wir im
baumarkt fahren werden und coole dinge
bauen werden also übermorgen kommt neuer
golffreunde weit gespannt wir bauen echt
dass ich weiß noch nicht ob es klappt
hätte aber wir versuchen was nachzubauen
bis dahin würde ich sagen dass ihr alle
cool bleibt bleibt gesund leben keine
drohungen das vor allem auch leichter
bei diesem video ist
[Musik]